moitié de l'audience des règles
acceptées représentative dans la fille
claudia face à juin jusque là ce qu'on
voit c'est quand même assez assez
satisfaisant il ya de très bonnes choses
il ya certains cavaliers pour qui c'est
la première la première grosse échéance
au niveau mondial donc on peut dire
qu'ils se débrouillent très bien parce
qu'ils ont des bonnes moyennes et puis
souhaitons que ça continue et que qui
continue toujours à progresser pour
vraiment arriver au top je pense qu'ils
sont sur le bon la bonne route pour
arriver là voilà parce qu'on a des bons
chevaux et des cavaliers de qualité en
france et il faut pas il faut pas se
voiler la face il faut bien reconnaître